"Я рідко заходжу в Інтернет". З цього починає свій виступ новий прем'єр.
Там можна прочитати дуже багато всього цікавого, у тому числі а про мене.
Я багато про себе дізнався нового…
Так новий прем’єр іронізує з приводу статей в інтернеті.
В останні дні усі видання збирали про нього інформацію.
Новий прем’єр Олексій Гончарук - не публічна персона. І нова в українській політиці.
Про нього дійсно відомо замало. Йому 35 років. За освітою юрист.
Працював за фахом, навіть має досвід робити радником міністра,
також працював в різних експертних організаціях, які за кошти міжнародних донорів
допомагали розробляти і впроваджувати реформи в Україні.
Зокрема, дерегуляцію економіки, спрощення умов для ведення бізнесу.
Схоже, це одна з головних цілей, що ставить перед собою новий прем’єр.
Я вже казав, що в Україні може бути іпотека в гривні по 12%-13%.
Це абсолютно точно можна зробити наступного року.
Вже цього року може знижатися відсоткова ставка за кредитами.
Люди почнуть робити бізнес. Це може запустити будівництво і промисловість.
Дешеве кредитування - одна з тактичних цілей, яку поставимо перед собою найближчим часом.
Новий прем’єр вважає, що в Україні може бути створено майже мільйон робочих місць.
Гончарук також обіцяє успішну боротьбу з бідністю, поганими дорогами, зруйнованою інфраструктурою.
Мета - зростання економіки на 5-7% щорічно.
Такі амбітні плани можуть бути реалізованими, вважає політолог Володимир Фесенко.
Адже, на думку експерта, Гончарук має непогані якості командного гравця.
Схоже, що в принципі він менеджер непоганий.
Плюс - важлива така деталь.
Якраз робота в Офісі президента засвідчила, що у нього є, я б сказав, такий
апаратний габітус, апаратна чуйка.
Він вміє і організувати роботу апарату, і вміє вибудувати, сформувати апаратні взаємини -
як з вищестоящим начальством, так і з підлеглими.
Ця командність - дуже важлива риса для Зеленського.
Олексій Гончарук відверто каже, що економіка України в жалюгідному стані.
За його даними, наступного року Україна кожну третю гривню
буде віддавати на погашення боргів перед міжнародними кредиторами.
Але і новий уряд, за словами прем’єра, планує розширити співпрацю з міжнародними донорами
за рахунок нових трирічних чи-то чотирирічних програм.
Резерви для зростання економіки, як і його попередник,
новий прем’єр бачить у боротьбі з контрабандою, у тому, що держава створить умови,
за яких  українці почнуть відкривати свої прибутки і сплачувати податки, а також у боротьбі з корупцією.
Ми досі не впоралися з тим, що хтось приходить до влади для того, щоб щось "пилити".
В новому уряді красти не будуть.
На думку політолога Володимира Фесенка, президент та його команда
дадуть Гончаруку більше можливостей та повноважень,
ніж експрезидент Петро Порошенко надавав експрем’єру Гройсману.
Більше того, прем’єр може стати дійсно самостійним.
Але тут інше важливе.
Новий прем’єр не має демонструвати надмірних політичних амбіцій. А він, схоже, людина амбітна.
Певний час, я думаю, він буде це приховувати.
Головна проблема для нього буде не в тому, чи він здатний до самостійності, чи ні.
У нього немає власної фракції, немає іншої політичної сили, на яку він може спиратися -
він повністю залежний у цьому сенсі і від Офісу президента, і від фракції "Слуга народу".
Поки у нового прем’єра є те, що не було у жодного з його попередників.
Підтримка більшост і парламенту і президента, а також силовиків з МВС, ГПУ і СБУ.
Новий уряд запропонує парламенту понад 30 законопроектів,
які, зокрема, блокують рейдерські захоплення, виведення коштів з України в офшори.
Можливо, відбудуться зміни і на ринку продажу землі.
Все це задля виконання головної мети - щорічного зростання економіки мінімум на 5%.
Гончарук вважає, що це реально, але зізнається, що новим міністрам буде дуже непросто.